the Joe Rogan experience oh it really
depends upon how it's used it can
benefit some people with some kind of
pain I don't think it's realistic to say
that some people that are in horrible
horrible pain would get the same
reaction that I get for opiates people
with like really bad burns for instance
24/7 addicted not for not medical
reasons I'm talking about if you're
become addicted to oh you know oxys
there's better drugs yeah there's better
drugs that get you off it yeah there's
quite a few that can help you probably
the most powerful and the most efficient
is ibogaine because like ayahuasca I
don't know I begins on ayahuasca
ayahuasca is a hallucinogenic that is
from South America it's
dimethyltryptamine ibogaine is from the
iboga tree and it's uh that's from
breaking open the head that the book
called breaking over that guy I'm sure
you did okay but ibogaine is like a Ruth
and it's something I have experienced
I'm just talking out of what I've read
essentially a ruthlessly introspective
twenty four-hour trip that rewires the
way your brain use addiction has a high
level of effectiveness interesting in
rehabilitating people like just is
killing the desire to do opiates huh
they're doing that in America Mexico you
go to Mexico can't go in America it's a
Leo in America of course is it like
sweat-lodge shaman type fingers in
hospital situation Hospital type
situations there's my buddy Edie clay
run say I think he still does runs a
clinic down in Mexico and he started it
because of his experiences with pills he
got hurt got on pain pills and had a
real bit hard time with them went to get
on ibogaine to get off the pain pills it
worked like a charm and he was like holy
[ __ ] I need to let people know about
this you can get your life back yeah and
it's not something you get addicted to
it's apparently something that one time
alright I'm doing it again yeah yeah
it's like it's rough yeah it's like the
okay that was enough yeah like DMT
exactly it's one of those ones enough
you did it once yeah yeah halogen and
that was sufficient you can get a lot
out of one yeah you know I had a plaid
plaid [ __ ] world
flying around it was it was full
out-of-body yachts oh yeah it's pretty
nuts yeah I think the difference in
ibogaine versus DMT DMT is ego
dissolving and very hallucinogenic and
you see these amazing visualizations
ibogaine seems to not have that but
instead be like deeply like to the
cellular level introspective and just
and and there's some sort of a physical
action that happens in the way your
brain the way your brain looks at
addiction changes pretty radically do
you need to be like pocher through it or
it just happens you should probably
think all those things should be done in
places where people gonna feel safe and
where people have done it before and
where people have experience with people
that have done it before and having a
real Center that have it has you know
real professionals and medical health
staff that's that's what you want and
the only thing that's keeping that from
happening in America and keeping
millions and millions of people from
getting off pills companies drug
companies yes
drug companies lobbying to keep all
these very helpful things illegal and
we're slowly but surely gonna work them
out and the way we're gonna work the
mouse through money that's why I like
the fact that marijuana has a 30% tax
make it 50 I don't give a [ __ ] what's a
joint how much is a joint sure I can get
you high all day
you
[Applause]